hello everyone I'm Alex kiriakidis live
in Amsterdam and I'm originally from
Greece as you might notice from my
popular accent I picked up you say yes a
long time ago I won the framework was
version zero point something and
actually I wrote the first book on v-j
yes because I wanted more people to
learn about Vijay yes because it's so
awesome
the book is called the majesty of you
say yes and whatever version available
for Vijay s12 and soon we'll publish one
for version 3 after the success of the
book I started view school thank you
what we teach developers through video
courses about you jes and the ecosystem
and I work as a consultant with a
handful of companies on Vijay yes and I
have contributed to the framework and
the ecosystem throughout the years you
can find me on the all social network
under the username of bootlicks and yeah
you should follow me on twitter if you
school our goal is to be the number one
learning resource for you say yes which
have more than 300 video lessons and 70
thousand users and all these amazing
people that you see here consist our
teaching team and they work with us in
the Stinson's contributors or reviewers
and please raise your hand if you have
learned something from view school
either from our video courses or
tutorials talks or anything awesome I
think I see some people but it's very
black here so besides of workshop we
also do workshops at the conferences and
in house for companies so if you would
like to tell with us let me know and
today I'm going to talk to you about
what you will love in view 3 but before
we look into that I want to talk a bit
about you jes as a framework and the
current state
so you jes is a relatively young
framework but it's very famous it's
being used by thousands of companies
worldwide and including some very big
companies like Google Apple Adobe
Behance
Nintendo and many more and the reason
what all these companies decide to use
with a yes in their application
is because you jes is so easy to use and
lead here we have a graph from from a
case study the state of JavaScript where
viuda yes developers were asked what is
their favorite aspect of user yes and as
you can see that you have placed the
easy learning curve as the first for
reference I have the same question here
to react developers and notice how they
shall place the easy learning curve
instead from the bottom this another
case studies con state of UJS and you
can see that the most important reason
behind adding views a yes to the tech
stack is because vgs is pretty easy to
start with and the biggest advantage is
the ease of integration and the great
documentation and of course all these
companies don't use UJ yes that's
because it's simple they use it because
it's a great it's a great framework and
it's lightweight its performant and it's
very scalable and if you're familiar
with UJ s you know that it's option
based it looks like that this is a
typical view component or view instance
and this doesn't go anywhere in view 3
we will continue to create our
components like this with the options
API that we know and love and all let's
talk a bit about u 3 u 3 is going to be
smaller and faster it comes with some
exciting new features it will expose
some lower-level api's while it comes
with improved active support and a more
maintainable code base you 3 is
currently in alpha so the syntax and
some features and saying this might
change and also what I'm going to show
you today might Saints but it's good to
know it's going to come out soon and
most of the user code will remain the
same so you will not need to rewrite
everything from scratch and now it's
time to talk about what I believe you
will love in view 3 and the first lovely
feature or change is that there will be
no reactivity caveats and currently due
to the limitations of JavaScript
if you cannot detect property edition
or deletion so when you are setting a
new array item adding a new object
property or deleting an object property
you cannot detect this change and dance
it's not reactive to work around this
feature in view to or the current
version we use a special view set and
view delete methods and selectively some
code examples to get you excited and get
what this reactivity Cavett's mean so
you see that in view to we in order to
set a new array item we will use the
view set method use the array as the
first argument the index where we want
to set it as a second and the new item
as the felt now in youth in view three
wouldn't you do anything special we will
just set the array item to the new value
and you will pick up the change and we
will be reactive out-of-the-box
accordingly when adding a new object
property thank you
when adding in your basic property you
can you use the view set you use the
object that's the first argument the
property name as a second and the new
value as the third and in VO three again
we don't have to do anything special we
set the object property and if it
doesn't exist it will be created and it
will be reactive and accordingly with
you delete we delete an object property
and then you three we just delete the
property and it works
isn't that awesome yeah you need to
answer another feature I'm very excited
in the view three and this one of my
favorites it supported and the portals
allow us to teleport an element in the
dome from one place to another let's
play once again Hey so in order to tell
about an element we need the target and
selectively a component to show you well
I'm rendering the router view and right
after I save a div with an ID of portal
target which is it's not a special
element is not a component or something
new in view three is just an empty div
with an ID
we'd say we will use to send elements
here from other components through
portals let me show you how this will
work
so this another component it's a user
card it it has a title for the user name
and the button that will remove the user
and within here I'm using the new portal
component that will be saved in view 3
which accepts a target argument with a
CSS selector of well to send this
element so whatever elements we place
within the portal will be rendered
inside the portal target which can be
anything we define here in this example
the target will be the div with ID of
portal target that we have enough view
and the source is this portal that lives
inside the template of user card and now
no matter where we place the user cut in
the in the document this element will
always go within the portal target so
you have made this example here is the
user card it has the name and this
button and here is the router if your
the rest contents of the page and notice
in the bottom that we have this element
that will be rendered within the target
so you see that the template of this
component is set on the top and the
bottom and now notice that if I totally
user card component both elements go
away so even though the this element
lives in the footer it actually belongs
within the user card component as I
frame the portals are very handy when
you are working with models
notifications and pop-ups and in general
elements that the position in the Dom
tree is important and also the handy one
you are going to play with some layout
content and imagine that you have the
power to add or remove content within a
sidebar a menu or a footer from any
component of your application if you get
overexcited with the porters and you
can't wait to use it there is a great
plugin for view too
called portal view it's made by forsen
and you can find it on this on this URL
and you can add it in your view
applications the next lovely change is
the multiple root nodes and this sounds
a bit complex but in reality it's very
simple let me know if this sounds
familiar to anyone you create a new
component you put your nice content
within the template and then you go in
the browser to see how it looks only to
see this error the template root
requires exactly one root element so
then you have to go back you create a
wrapper element and you put all the
elements within this like wrapper div
span or whatever and then you go back
and then place now in view three this
does works we don't have to do anything
you you don't need to create any wrapper
components or divs anymore so in YouTube
we would have to create a div and place
the multiple root nodes here or nodes
and in view 3 we can have multiple root
nodes directly on the template the next
lovely change is regarding the v-model
api
and the v-model API changes from this to
this so now you might say why the heck
would I like that what what's what's the
benefit for me and the benefit is that
this way you can not only have one B
model on your component not two but as
many as B models as you like okay and
now it's time for a serious a new
feature that is very exciting and this
is no other than the infamous
composition API the composition API is a
new advanced feature it's an addition to
the calendar API and the options API is
not being deprecated it's also in RFC
status so the syntax might change and
you should not use it in production just
yet
typically here I would have a ton of
code examples and use cases but I know
that many people have talked about the
topic already so I will just make a
quick intro and give you my thoughts on
the composition API the composition API
is here to help us with the code
organization the logically huge and with
typescript support and the benefits of
the composition API when compared with
other existing patterns is that it's
extremely flexible because it is
essentially JavaScript functions they
can be stored in individual files that
can be customized with arguments and
everything and when they when the
conversion API is used to sell component
options there is a clear source of
properties so you know where we said
data or methods are coming from and
there is no magic happening behind the
scenes as you would have with mix-ins
and there's also a performance benefit
because there are no component instances
involved and there is no namespace
collision as with mixes there are some
cases where the composition api is a
great fit and the first one is when the
component code grows too long
and
how many of you have worked with a
component that it's more than 1,000
lines 1,000 lines yeah see quite so many
people yeah so guys for this use cases
the composition API will be a blessing
because we can split this component into
multiple files and we can split them by
feature and then bring them all together
the composition API is also a great fit
when there is multiple people that work
on the same big components and when you
want to reuse component options without
using mixings and lastly of course when
taps keep support is important though as
everything in life the compulsion api
comes with its own drawbacks which in my
opinion is the overhead of introducing
graphs and the fact that there is no set
template the same we have with mix-ins
and the Lebanon calve and the letting
can form is the most important because
remembering the intro how many people
and companies love you jes because it's
so simple and their learning can be so
smooth so please consider this and don't
go crazy you don't need to rewrite your
view to application using the
composition API you don't need to use
the composition API in a single
component and keep the junior developers
in mind and this is something that I
really like in VJ yesterday that you can
teach someone that ok here is your data
your compute properties your probes
whatever and then they can build amazing
things they don't need to be experts but
the composition API is not so friendly
to junior developers or back-end
developers web designers and people that
are no experts in JavaScript or
development in general and also spends
this is not a joke this is a new
component in nuj yes that renders some
fallback content instead of a component
and delay condition is met
so suspense accepts some slot and the
default slot except the component that
should be displayed and while this
component performs some a synchronous
operations suspense will display the
fallback template will scan be allowing
indicate there is something else so we
don't need to worry which template will
be displayed
because suspends will take care of this
for you now this is a place called the
slide because I think you're going to
love the next the next sense how many of
you use views AES filters and you really
like them yeah I don't see very few
people and this is great because saying
you three filters are removed so what
you would do with with a filter today
you would use it in the template using
the pipe symbol and the filter name and
the common use case is when you work
with a currency for example if you have
an amount and you want to be paid in
dollars and this is not possible if you
three anymore instead you would create a
method and pass the value as the
argument so the benefit of this is that
there is no more D'Alema you don't need
to worry if you should make a filter or
a method because they do the same thing
because there will be no filters yeah
what I'm showing you now is the is it
same thing to change that I believe you
will love but quite some more changes
some you might love some you might say
it or not even care but to mention if
you the global mounting API is will
change the transparent apples will be
simpler the sludge will be unified and
quite some more
let's see some hints first of all you
three will not break your applications
so even though you will need to take
some time to upgrade your application
you will not need to rewrite everything
from scratch
also if you are not already using views
AES in your products or even if you
don't know if you say yes you don't need
to wait for view 3 in order to use it or
learn it because most of the surface API
will be the same it will just be better
and if you are still wondering why to
upgrade to view 3 a quick summary is
because you will get massive performance
improvements exceptional reusability
possibilities and all these exciting new
features new design patterns for
scalability and types keep support filly
brickowski and I were working on a
course that is called what's new in view
3 that we are going to publish in a
couple of weeks
well actually cover this and the other
features that you might not necessarily
love and you can find it here
and if you want to get notified when we
see it you can click this follow button
on the side you take a photo okay that's
that's me I'm Alex collections are the
widows and workshops at you school
mostly every single one of you should
give got and 25 bucks free pass when you
arrived in your bag if you not look
around as you scroll we create courses
for beginners intermediate and advanced
developers weekly we try to have like as
big bite as we can we have server-side
rendering Knox is testing real-world
cases and many more and actually with
the passes you can get access to all our
courses for free so you can Sakai all
our content yeah
don't check this secure code is old so
we will be the booth area in the last
break if you want to come say hi discuss
about the training or just grab some
stickers I will be happy to meet you
thank you
you